ما رأيك في هذه المحاولة التي قام بها
فلاديمير بوتين وشي
جينبينغ لمحاولة إظهار القوة
بشكل جيد ، هذا ما كانا يريدان
القيام به طوال الوقت ، تتذكر أنهما خصصوا
تحالفًا استراتيجيًا قبل بدء الحرب
فعليًا في عام 2022 لكن الصين لم تفعل ذلك.
كانوا صريحين جدًا ، فهم
يفهمون قوة العقوبات ، كما أنهم
ينظرون إلى روسيا على أنها حليف خاسر
وليسوا متلهفين جدًا للدخول في
ذلك ، وفي النهاية سنفكر في الأمر
من منظور الصين ، فهم يحبون
التكنولوجيا الروسية وهم بالتأكيد  يريدون
الهيدروكربونات ولكن آخر شيء
يريده شي جين بينغ حقًا هو
إعادة بناء الاتحاد السوفيتي ذي الصلاحيات الفائقة على
حدود الصين ، وبالتالي فإن روسيا الضعيفة التي
يتم القبض عليها وهي تأتي إليه للمساعدة وهذا أمر
مُرضٍ جدًا للرئيس
الحادي عشر ، نعم ، هناك نقطة جيدة تقودنا إلى
ما يحدث الآن  في
ساحة المعركة بشكل عام مع
حرب الخنادق الوحشية هذه في الشرق ، على سبيل المثال ،
أنت تعلم أنها موجودة هناك نحن في
مأزق استراتيجي بشكل أساسي و
والسبب في ذلك هو أن روسيا فقدت
قدرتها الهجومية لكن الأوكرانيين
لم يكونوا كذلك ليس لديهم ما يكفي من
المدفعية
وليس لديهم ذخيرة مدفعية كافية وليس لديهم
طائرات بدون طيار وليس لديهم
طائرات مقاتلة ليس لديهم  لديك أه دبابات جديدة حتى
لا يكون لديهم حقًا
القوة النارية الهجومية لإنهاء هذا الشيء
، وفي رأيي أن الطريقة الصحيحة للقيام
بذلك هي منحهم تلك القدرة على
إخراج روسيا من أوكرانيا ومن ثم هناك
احتمال معقول أن  يمكن أن نجري
هذه المحادثات ، لكن بدلاً من ذلك ، هناك
مأزق طاحن ينتظر
روسيا إما أن تنزف أوكرانيا
أو أن يضع الغرب أخيرًا
إجراءات جرائم حرب فعالة ضد الرئيس
بوتين والتي من شأنها أن تجعله يتعافى
ويقطع أي دعم دولي ، نعم
نحن  سأرى ما إذا كان هذا سيحدث أه أوكرانيا الآن
تقول أنه منذ غزو بوتين أوكرانيا
في فبراير الماضي ، قام الجنرال الأوكراني
بتحرير حوالي 1800
مستوطنة أوكرانية من الاحتلال الروسي.
الأوكرانيون مع استمرار هذه
الحرب الفظيعة على
الإطلاق ، أعني أن هذه حقيقة كبيرة هي
أن أوكرانيا يمكن أن تقاوم وتحتفظ
بمفردها ثم تستعيد الأراضي التي
تقول للعالم إن روسيا
قادرة على هزيمة روسيا القادرة على
طردها بالكامل.  أوكرانيا
ولكن حسنًا إذا كانت ساحة المعركة تتغير
لأن ما فعله الروس هو
ترسخ أنفسهم حقًا في
الدونبو ولذا فلن يكون الأمر مثل
الاستيلاء السهل على مفتاح السيارة حتى في
الشمال الشرقي الذي حدث في سبتمبر ،
القتال الذي تخوضه أوكرانيا  يجب
عليهم المضي قدمًا هو
أنهم سيضطرون إلى استخدام مدفعية جماعية سيكون عليهم
امتلاك قوة قتالية ساحقة في
نقطة حاسمة وتحقيق اختراق على
الخطوط الروسية وهم غير
مجهزين للقيام بذلك حتى الآن  يطلب
من الولايات المتحدة هذا النوع من
الدعم حقًا الولايات المتحدة فقط
وإلى حد ما يمكن لألمانيا توفير
ذلك ، وأعتقد أن هذه قضية
سياسية يتعين على واشنطن النظر فيها  د
العزم